so this part
who's the headmaster how do you know it
College
hopefully a fresh start I'll do your
most good I'm sure it will so is that
Lisi Westman girl oh you mean my future
wife any questions yes what's it the
belt that's just something I do excuse
me
your son is in my class French yes he's
very advanced how would you like to be
Miss West middle somewhat partner
I'm afraid any hopes you had of us
having while gymnastics acts are
destined to be frustrated gotcha are
your parents still together a mom passed
away which way the only way you're going
to feel better is if we figure out some
way for you to let her go but just to
find you I wanted you to have the car
and how are you gonna get around just
never seen you ride a bike my entire
life I assure you I am perfectly capable
of it sorry
there's a free concert Friday absolutely
to go we could eat together yes we can
eat together make sure this isn't a
driver's seat
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
she'd be proud of us
[Music]
you